hello and welcome back to the 2013 u.s.
Chess Championship we have some big news
I'm Jennifer Shahade e this is
grandmaster yasser sarah juan and it
looks like those stats about the
marshall gambit are gonna have to be
Marshall attack rather as they call it
are gonna be have to be revised slightly
because out of the 5500 games which
black had a resounding edge in run out
to add +1 to the white column here
because John Bryant one of the lowest
rated players in the tournament
qualifying by the US Open it looks like
he's gonna bust out a Gregory tied on up
here in this game he just played this
really nice move f5 which caused
resignation they're just too many pins
and scores here right yes exactly f4 f5
something had went wrong from Gregory's
point of view a little bit earlier but
the moment white was able to sacrifice
in exchange grab a couple of pawns this
move Bishop e5 putting the bishop in the
middle of the board central domination
black had no attack and suddenly with
this move of f4 f5 it was all over it's
over because let's look at some of the
variations both if he now if he tries to
play Bishop takes f5 right there's my
mouse yeah
recapture with a knight takes and then
after work takes f5 yes
now after Bishop takes d5 yes you just
can't hold on to all your pieces right
because if we take with a queen we've
lost this rook Queen takes rook and if
we take with the pawn oops
we that's even worse we lose the Queen
so the traditional way of playing array
Lopes and grabbing the pond lives one
more day today exactly one further point
is after Knight takes Queen takes now as
you were mentioning too many pins and
skiers and this move Bishop takes d5
there's just one single check we step
aside and we this rook is hanging this
rook is hanging - no Jax - no checks
so very impressive victory by John today
as he as you mentioned one of the lower
rated players in the tournament has
scored two victories and one draw to put
himself amongst the tournament leaders
and in a post pre-tournament interview
with Vijay master on my client he's also
doing a lot of the reported here for the
Chess Club and also for chess life he
interviewed Brian and asked what's your
goal in this tournament and Brian said
first place well that's the right
attitude and he's he's on his way if he
continues to play like this despite
being one of the lowest rate of players
in the field now you're gonna get him on
the air and just to just a bit and we
also have a another exciting guest in
studio today it's a Sunday so we've got
a lot of visitors from from colleges in
the area a lot of dignitaries I'm very
happy that honored joins is this she's
on our Lindenwood team and I am being
paid to coach the London with team after
you get a chance to meet honour you'll
realize instantly that I'm not being
paid enough wait don't you mean the
opposite I was hoping you'd pick up yeah
we're gonna have them with you in just a
minute
right okay Anna sure ovitch four-time
Belarusian champion I believe and and
commentator as well she's done fantastic
commentary all around the world visiting
earlier of one of your teammates is the
assertion wanted good coach
[Laughter]
alright guys well I love that boy and
I'm Anna yeah I'm not gonna give her any
homework for the next month that's not
the way to end a way to get her to the
next level right oh really
mm-hmm it is a great deal of fun to work
with so many very very promising
talented young people and to coach the
London with team is really a great
pleasure oh yeah it's so much fun and
it's great when they also have interests
outside of chess you know I know close
to kaput ski is you know tweeting us
like all sorts of little jokes he's
putting in through the broadcast and
well Nolan wants to come on and share
some stories but we're having a lot of
interesting tweets about the women's
championships actually I think we're
gonna address one by Robert Bernard
who goes by Bionic lion online and he
hashtag to us chess champs as well and
he asked about the rivalry between Irina
crushed and Ana's at on ski weather that
was mostly something that we
commentators and reporters like to hype
up or whether it was really real and I
was doing at the truth is somewhere in
between a few years ago I would say that
it was extremely real because there was
this um infamous playoff game before the
championships were in st. Louis so that
would have been six years ago and on an
AI arena were so neck-and-neck that they
kept splitting games in the playoffs
they had to stand up her points in the
tournament they kept splitting games and
finally they had to go to this
Armageddon gam right where it was
sudden-death it was only five minutes to
four minutes right pieces were just
lying you mean it was like something you
would see and when you know you have a
few drinks and play with your cheapest
chess set so nothing gets damaged right
pieces flying all over the room coffee
house Blitzen exactly a non ended up
winning and it was very controversial
with fans of both ladies like you know
just kind of jumping in and making noise
and
I think after that there was a period of
of a real animosity but then you know
they've been teammates on championship
Olympic teams for so long and I think
they're they're on good terms again and
the rivalry is more solidly on the board
right exactly I mean when you play on
the US Olympic team you want your
teammates to do exceptionally well so
the team can collectively win a medal
and although you do have intense
rivalries like you see but for example
between gada Kamsky Karan Nakamura when
it comes to team competition they really
are supportive of one another so that
little mixture makes you mellow and
chill a little bit more I mean it looks
like our guests are ready for take to
hear Grandmaster Maurice Ashley and
women's Grandmaster a nice Rivage indeed
back with an acerbic
so you are saying that Anna that Yassir
is a great coach and I think we got cut
off right at that point what makes the a
so such a great coach well you know you
guys to have him here like every day and
you know Chan I'm so jealous but she was
sitting next to yesterday
Yassir has always been mr. Jay smooth
you know he's cool even back in the day
so you are a commentator what is it like
seeing this kind of setup you know just
has really been growing in recent years
and the technology has been so much
better
presenting the game what have you seen
on the international level yeah you know
I'm very happy that chess is growing
like a commercial product that were able
to sell it well under it's really great
that TV is very interested in taking
part in covering the tournaments and
especially you know US Championships and
I think that it can be considered an
example for the rest of the world how
its organized here because for example
taking account my experience oh it
wasn't on this high level you know I
mean like the technique side of the
project so it's really cool I'm happy
for you guys that you're working like
with just this kind of technique yeah
it's great to know that that this is the
best you've seen so far what
you doing here at Lindenwood I mean
you're far away from home in Belarus
yeah pursuin must have degree in public
a public administration very good and
you're playing for the team have you had
a chance to play for the team yet or
play any matches or play for the plane
pulling in wood here it's a great honour
for me to play for American University
and actually we're and in Pinal for is
so close to get into the final for the
last round who are playing against
Webster being so and we had really good
chances and Webster is right here as
well they're your main rivals is it a
big deal that Susan Polgar eyes come
with Webster team and you're at
Lindenwood and there's got to be some
rival you're here in st. Louis
well you know I cannot say that we're
rivals you know Susan's team the only
high-level because they have like longer
history we have just started this is we
our team hasn't existed even one year so
we are on our way to improve and to grow
so that's why I think that we can just
look at them and try to develop and ask
for some advices why not it's more like
you know they're like older brother or
sister for us when we're playing
tournaments yes they said kind of rivals
like normal sports but our attitude we
will respect them a lot
indeed so finally what's your next
project you're going to be doing any
more commentary on the international
stage and each other soon well right now
I don't know because recently it was in
March in Kazakhstan with comment' and
the Women's World Team Championship and
actually the US team was taking part
there well in the numerous time going
just to study you know and well it will
be summer break for the tournaments like
for the University tournaments so
probably till fall we're not going to
play for the university but maybe some
tournaments like open tournaments and
you know Chicago on some other
tournaments well we wish you the best of
luck in all those events thank you so
much for joining us and a share of each
for time women's Belarusian champion and
wonderful commentator and apparently
and of yasss erawan Thank You Jenny yes
thank you thank you she's jealous of me
that's a great battery
lucky me those of you uh you know
watching you online you didn't get to
see Anna's shoes because I'm jealous of
her
oh yes yes very very good-looking shoes
I must admit well let's go back to the
Women's Championship so we've got as it
hath gained crush the Battle of the
Women's Championship here and we just
addressed the rivalry certainly
rivalries on the board somebody
mentioned we also got a tweet from close
tchaikovsky one of Ana's teammates at
Lindenwood and he said that these guys
should have decided over the board
rather than on playoffs right
I mean his words were as a taunts can
crush don't want to play another playoff
their fate gets decided right here right
now well certainly the opening for that
attitude because the Kings Indiana so
glad it's less likely than other
openings to Peter out into a draw in the
early stages precisely and it and it has
gone into a double edged game arena did
get to advance her pawn with g5 g 494
anna this is where we had left it what
anna is trying to do on her side of the
table is to take possession of the b6
square for her night
well arena on the other side is simply
aiming all of her forces against White's
King and trying to deliver checkmate
this move takes on g4 that was a little
bit of a surprise for me in truth since
Black has invested so much time
advancing the pawn to g4 generally they
that black likes to keep that tension
but arena had a very specific idea in
mind which was to develop this Bishop on
c8 that had been spectating in the game
and at least to give her rook some
freedom of movement after Bishop g4
Queen f2 again notice that black white
pardon me is aiming to control the
square b6
we had the Meuse Bishop g7 2f8 takes
takes and now king h1 okay what anna is
visualizing is that there's going to be
a future rook g7 so it's a kind of a
prophylaxis move
she gets her king out of danger before
that danger even appears and now Knight
h7 that's a nifty little move intention
is very clear by black to bring the
Knight to g5 putting pressure on f3 as
well as e4 and Bishop b4 but on the
other hand it's already protected so
let's see how Oh Queen b6 could be and I
knew at some point from White's point of
view won't be sick so we don't have any
problem trading Queens black would have
a big problem trading cream so Queen f6
again preparing when necessary or simply
if necessary to defend upon with rook da
and now after which C - we have another
rich struggle which we'll come back to
but let's take a quick look at our first
board in the championship section got a
camps B versus Christensen before we go
to our in-studio guests here all right
at this moment when we had left it that
was that beautiful little pirouette idea
that Maurice had shared after this move
G for Maurice pointed out that knight on
c6 could go to d4 attacking the square
c2 he looked at the various captures
found him wanting suggested rook c7 and
then there was knight c6 with the idea
of taking control of the f4 square and I
like Larry's position after that nice
little strategic maneuver that didn't
take place the g4 b6 was played and then
the players have played I don't want to
say routinely because that's never
really how they play you get into
trouble if you play too routinely in a
time control like this
I would rather say that the players have
played normally up to this moment
notice that White's pieces are sitting
nicely using this efore square in one
case is for the night now for the bishop
still the juries come out as to who yeah
exactly
whoa whoa eight five okay b-59 a 597 and
Kamsky just maybe seven okay so if we're
take c5 there's there's a night and
night b7 rule with a fork against rook
and rook here let's assume one of them
protects the other I'm not sure exactly
which way in this case what we would see
is White's rook on a1 which had been
doing nothing grabbing this pawn and
this looks very unpleasant for Larry in
this position very strange in this
tournament we've seen so many imbalances
Arbour work for two pieces it was pretty
extraordinary yeah we get it again well
in this case that's just a variation
because Larry declined that variation
instead of after Bishop takes e5 it
looks like he played Knight f4 a counter
attacking on D 3 and H 3 and H 3 trance
so then do we have and Bishop simply
goes to the board position so we will be
right back to this game but now let's go
to John Bryan who is now on two and a
half out of three one of the lowest rate
of players in the field and he's just
playing fantastically and he's with
Maurice indeed gen John Bryant
giant-killer we're gonna have to call
you congratulations on your victory
today thank you
well did you expect to see Gregory card
I don't play a Marshall gambit I mean
Marshall is pretty sharp opening did you
expect to see it no it was a surprise
but I did look at it a little bit
because he has played it before and you
went straight for what looks like a main
line you accepted it most players in
these days
of declining on the highest level and
the the host
Jenny eyes were pointing out that the
stats they tend to favor black in the
Marshall but you seem to want the pollen
and just grab it and go for it yeah I
don't think that why should ever be
worse there's so many lines that lead to
white having a pawn up with a obstacle
or bishop endgame and that's how black
draws that being lower rated if that
happened I don't think I could be
unhappy with that very good point very
good point as a matter of fact well
disposition occurred it looked like you
were doing just fine and then you played
this explosive move c4 and after he took
it looked like his position was under
tremendous pressure as if it was about
to collapse here yeah that I'm the one
attacking now so so you felt very
confident right at this moment yeah I
was a c4 is probably my one of my top
two favorite moves of the game top - all
right well take over the next few he
played the move rook a to c8 and you
played this move rookie six yeah and and
just let tell me what were you thinking
right at this point well I thought that
he only has two moves rook d8 and wreck
f6 and Rick f6 is pretty bad alright so
he played you played this and then you
just stole upon I mean you're playing
Gregory card I know one of the great
players in the country did you just feel
like so what
yeah the well I just saw that after f4
you know the game so you were prepared
to see f4 happen which which in fact did
happen and you sacrificed here and then
you ripped off this pawn collecting a
ton of pawns for the exchange clearly
and after rook over Bishop to e5 another
attacking move piece draw back and it
just looked like you were rolling here
rook to c1 and when did you know like
right at this point here after f4 did
you start seeing the tactics based on
the interference or did he just when you
saw Queen e6 you realize it was a
blunder
positional move so you didn't see a five
right away like my clear and I just
added the idea of f5 interfere beautiful
move this move f5
interfering with the bishop and take us
through a variation if if if Bishop were
to take the pawn which looks like the
most natural move how would how would
you finish let's start with the rook
maybe the most crushing Bishop takes d5
and now he whichever way he takes I if
he takes the C pawn then it opens up my
rook adding an attacker in c8 and if he
takes with the Queen then he's removing
a defender for the riveter so you win
big time matter of fact yeah pretty
devastating position Wow that's a cold
cut crush you're now sitting on two and
a half out of three you're one of the
lower rated players in the tournament
what's your feeling going forward
actually I heard a comment when you were
asked what would constitute a successful
tournament you had a tour to answer was
first place haha that's pretty brave
stuff are you still feeling that way
about the tournament now well going into
the tournament I wasn't so sure but now
I'm I've gained confidence I got a good
mood now
fantastic well congratulations feat a
master John Bryan one of the lower rated
players in the event two and a half out
of three pretty special score right now
and looking pretty good Jenny yes
beautiful beginning and I guess it just
goes to show in order to have this type
of spectacular result you have to aim
high absolutely well I mean set your
goals high and try to achieve them and
John is really lighting up this 2013
event feed a master not even the
Grandmaster title two and a half
a lot of players are looking at him and
saying wow who is this young man again
having very very special result anything
in norms at this tournament as well
absolutely kudos that'll be another nice
thing to watch out for so we were just
looking at the Kamsky christensen game
that the key battle here today
absolutely on board one between our two
perfect scores in this tournament and we
have another result while you're playing
up the position Kashia Anshuman was a
draw huh okay very good
we had this position maybe this was an
overreach by Larry because probably he
missed this Bishop takes e5 he did go
for Knight f4 which as we've seen does
for quite spawn so black does not lose
upon giving up this pawn on c5 had to
have been an error in my view Knight
takes h3 so Larry wins back his pawn but
trading the trade and white is happy to
trade that h3 pawn which is on the yeah
far side of the board for central pawn
like the c5 this is much more likely to
become relevant pawn yeah precisely and
with this move d4 essentially I think
gada has established I'm not I'm not
gonna say winning position but a big
advantage for gada at this moment in the
game well okay so advantage gotta and we
were also getting into the arena crush
and honor the fans gave out also yes
popping over to that one you only have
an hour left and the time control and I
think this this is gonna start to
clarify and this game has been heating
it it's almost been like a slow build
you know you do it so far yeah you
simply put a pot of water on the stove
and slowly slowly bubble start magically
appearing and before you know it's a
cauldron and check this out
remember I'm talking philosophically
about the opening how black is supposed
to go student body over to the Kings
side and White's supposed to go student
body over to the Queen side and just
check out this formidable-looking lineup
of pea
says along the G file with this last
move rook f8 to g7 that's scary-looking
it is it need and from whites point of
view all of her pieces have kind of
masked a little bit over here on the
queenside already so like I say when I'm
white in these positions I don't like
everybody aiming at my king so I'd feel
nervous with uh with Ana's position but
this is the nature of this particular
defense so with rook c7 busts through on
the Queen side exactly we really do want
to trade off at least a piece of those
attackers exactly because we don't I
mean that's the only way to defend
defend by attacking in the King's Indian
right you can't really I mean you've
seen examples where people manage to set
up a fortress on the Kings side and play
with g4 or whatever but for the most
part we don't really want to touch those
pawns and we're just not gonna be able
to bring enough defenders over so we
want to defend by trading off the
enemies right right get rid of those at
strong attacking pieces here this is an
interesting
I'm not so happy about arenas decision
rookie 87 here I see this bishop
actually as being this stalwart defender
of this g2 Square and maybe I'm wrong
but my initial gut reaction would be to
capture that Bishop and bring my bishop
to h3 hoping that I could bring an
assault down on the g2 square
I'm not saying black white doesn't have
defenses she obviously does but that
would have been my approach to this
visit position arena shows rookie 7 yeah
maybe she was afraid of taking on g7 and
sorry in this line yeah let's say taking
on and well first or second yeah and
then after and maybe something like yeah
maybe Brooke do you want ID of similar
to arenas win against Elena cats is kind
of doing the unusual and actually I
keep eyeing the g5 was white air mm-hmm
and she thought that didn't like this
position for some reason perhaps I don't
know I think this Bishop is a real nasty
animal and a mule it sorry I'm working
on perfecting my arrows it does both on
the offense and defense and let's just
clear the oops
butchy one let me make that sorry and
let me just clear the g5 for a moment I
think it's anybody's game here I think
it's still up in the air all three
results are possible
absolutely maybe maybe now Anna will try
to hit on the d6 pawn play Knight c4
right so the knight c4 makes perfect
sense
going after the d6 pawn again I'm
clearing the G file so I'm hoping that
in the future one day this move Knight
h4 might cause some discomfort and we
have a grandmaster Maurice actually with
apparently some bad news for Ray
Robinson breaking news indeed a terrible
position about to take place for a
Robson you know pawns are tiny we call
them the soul of chess but they're so
tiny you think they can't do too much
damage well in this game
serpents Keys H pawn is doing a world of
hurt on robsons position take a look
here in this moment Robson played the
movie for seemingly attacking this
knight on f3
unfortunately that actually wasn't the
case because of this pin along this line
so he couldn't quite take the knight so
Chaplinsky ignored it and play this move
h5
so in order to get this threat going
Robson played the move Bishop e7
thinking you know I get to take your
knight now except suppose he ignored him
and captured on this square and now if
pawn takes Knight then suddenly this
move Queen to e6 check and the king goes
in the corner Queen takes f5 and the
Queen has all the plans in the world to
go to h3 and then deliver a nasty
checkmate you get that right a nasty
checkmate down on 87 and possibly h8 too
much of an attack so he hadn't
this had Robson in this position let's
get back to here and so he played Queen
to d7 guarding the e6 square except
suddenly the move Knight takes e4 BAM
coming out of nowhere sacrificing this
Knight
the point being that if pawn takes
simply Queen takes and the pin is back
on the e-file but more importantly the
Queen is thinking about exiting stage
right and getting this checkmate again
on 87 and possibly h8 nothing to do
about it he's simply going to get
crushed is Robson and it's looking
really bad for the collegiate the
collegian you know the college players
have been complaining that it's probably
not the right thing to do to be doing
finals and then the very next day try to
play in the US Championship I think this
is proving them right genin yes big ask
playing what Maurice just said preparing
for the finals and then getting a
different kind of exam here at the US
Championship
absolutely all those for some players I
said Jaclyn I think they are already
finished yeah I think a rata Robert Hass
as well so it depends on college to
college right but it's close enough that
you hardly recover from the exams before
you're here in the US Championships and
again Ray has been recently he played in
Brazil for the US team one of our shiny
lights he had an outstanding result in
Brazil helping the United States qualify
for the World Team Championship so the
United States owes its success to Ray
Robson I thought as did Gregory cut off
that Ray came into this tournament as
not a favorite but it's certainly a dark
horse and a person who could easily
upset the field having a bad bad break
out of the start he lost and drew and
looks like he's losing today as Maurice
just showed too bad indeed oh we should
actually take a look at a game that we
haven't seen in a while by two of our
top scorers a halt in Ramirez exactly
wrong-o because we just had a little bit
of a freeze on our technical position I
would like to just go back to that
position for a moment on gotta calm skis
board and I was poor Larry was suffering
mightily in that game yeah no indeed
yeah we were looking at that game and
even though we thought Larry's opening
was good too to rehash it seems that
Larry myths a little tactical
combination if you look at the webcam as
we're seeing right now I saw just that I
mean I've played Larry so often it and I
know his mannerisms expression so very
well there he got gave that little
grimace is you know got a recaptured on
d4 with the bishop was like so Larry's
bearing down but I think he already done
too much damage to his position so that
would give if
Kamsky manages to win this game that
would put him a half a point ahead of
the field and the only player who would
still be in contention for that pitcher
$64,000 prize
absolutely don't forget a perfect score
it's the $64,000 exactly a very unlikely
but yeah well a 3o start is the ideal
right if you're gonna win it you got to
start with 3-0 that's the only way to
get there and we've had a couple
questions on today he's earlier Maurice
was talking with pretty-pretty Bosch
about the world championship which is
gonna be held in Chennai India and we
got a couple questions about who we
think is going to win that match we
would be an on door will be magnus
carlsen
mmm-hmm okay well definitely I'm happy
to share first of all i think that the
pide did make a mistake already were
literally out of the box as we know just
a few weeks ago magnus carlsen the
world's highest rated player did win the
right to challenge world champion
Viswanath on the non from the candidates
tournament in London so I fully expected
as did
I think every chess fan who has followed
chess for the better part of 10 years
expected a bidding process an auction
where cities around the world would put
forward their best bid and the highest
bidder would win the competition to host
the championship yes I heard a rumor the
other day that Paris was going to host
it and I was just having these fantasies
of flying from Philly to Paris and
needing an Urkel saw you and me both
watching Magnus you know I'll play a
beautiful sacrificial game it was like
all replaying in my head and then and
then and then what really surprised was
about a week ago is that fidei announced
they had signed an mou and Memorandum of
Understanding with organisers in India
and Chennai without the bidding process
whoa whoa whoa whoa said Magnus is
Magnus and his managers what happened to
the auction and the bidding process if
you'd a say we've never received a
complaint
the Norwegian Chess Federation promptly
sent a letter of complaint to the fidei
keeping in mind that in the fidei the
members are federations I an individual
cannot complain it's the member
Federation's that complain and norway
norwegian federation complained very
shortly after the norwegian chess
federation complaint was published it
was announced by the French Federation
that they were looking to host the match
in Paris then today I heard from the
internet essentially that fidei confirms
that Chennai will host the event
completely ignoring a bid from Paris
that is 30% higher financially higher
monitor monetarily I see well I mean I'd
certainly I'm sure that no matter where
it is it'll be a fantastic match and the
organisers will do a great job hosting
it of course being so much closer to
Paris most of our most of our listeners
here at the club and our American
audience might prefer to be able to take
that eight hour plane ride but I'm sure
the Indian people would be very excited
they're suppose to be so popular in
India chess right and
is absolutely a Michael Jordan there
right he is a national hero
and so the Indian people and the Indian
organizers would love to host the match
but it kind of goes so the hold on I
mean to go backwards and forwards so
yeah who's gonna win back that's gonna
win the problem is I see it is is there
gonna be a match is Magnus going to be
very so very unhappy about the way the
fidei handled the awarding of the match
that he's saying no no no I don't like
this it doesn't feel right let's just
have a proper organic auction if the
Indians win the auction I will play in
India stalling on the question or put
you on the clock okay when we're back
for Maurice who's got something from
Christians and in Kamsky we're gonna ask
for a one-word answer from you okay get
it in this game it turns out that it
looked as though Kristensen may have
been worse as yaz mentioned but actually
the computer says he was completely fine
but then he blundered horribly and
Kamsky missed it well let's take a look
at the details in this position here the
computer says that after pawn takes pawn
takes this move Knight to b4 unveiling
an attack of the rook on this bishop was
very strong for black and in fact if
rook over to d1 protecting it this
fantastic move Knight to d3 blocking the
line so that this rook can still attack
this bishop would have been very
powerful the move Bishop to e3 was its
best suggestion and then this move total
chaos not total chaos but kind of crazy
you have to look at this to calculate to
make sure everything's okay but
according to the computer this would
have been a nice way to go instead
Larry played the move Knight to e6
attacking the bishop on d4 and comc had
a superstar move right now
Knight to c6 looks like the knight is
hanging but if you capture then suddenly
Pau
takes comes with a fork on both these
pieces the knight on e6 and the rook on
c6 definitely better for white here but
come ski in turn miss that idea and
instead he simply captured on d5 here
and black is back in the game when
Knight takes d4 according to computer
this position is equal so some crazy
things happen in his face of just two
moves and the fight continues gen and
yes you know funny because several years
ago before computers were the monsters
they are they were always good at that
kind of stuff
those surprising moves especially the
ones that are in the short term and you
just wouldn't look at knight c6 you know
random like little real sacrifices and
travelogue just who's one of the most
creative players out there was saying
how useful it was for you're calculating
skills to really go through those types
of tactics and train yourself so as
yourself against the computer because
they're so tactically a day for those
things so yeah that it's a it's not
exactly surprising to see players of
this little miss things because that's
what makes us human right well a lot of
people miss things right well you've got
your blinders on you see a specific line
of play that in a sense you've chosen to
accept like you're expecting your
opponent to play this you'll play that
and so forth and so on and so there was
that little nuance but to be frank and
to be honest
got a Kamsky world class player usually
picks up on those little tactics and
maybe he's not feeling a hundred percent
maybe not in any case a full body
full-bodied struggle still ahead and all
three results possible even with the
Queen's off the board there's plenty of
fun to be had
yes or you're not getting off the hook
with your one-word answer I'm favoring
Magnus even though but but you think the
the location being India will make it a
little closer probably right that's a
home court advantage I don't see it that
way
I actually think if it's a negative for
vichy because
we understand in sports that the home
court advantage is very very real but in
the world of chess can you imagine all
of these Indian journalists across the
whole body of India want to have
interviews with Anand after the game
before the game how you doing what are
you doing
Anand obviously the Hindi speaker none
of them are gonna be running after
Magnus so I'm thinking that it's
actually going to be a handicap
interesting and I guess it's actually I
guess it's also the fact that for World
Championship Lee the Challenger will
come so early so that that question of
jet lag not used to the food all that
thing because you have so many resources
when you're playing for the World
Championship but that wouldn't be as
much of an issue if say you're
travelling on a sports team and have to
go to a new location every single day or
you don't have the resources to you know
really exactly where and what you what
you eat but let's take a look at a
Robson game because I'm sorry not the
Robson game we already I already oh it's
not over yet but Maurice was showing us
how it's almost all our so yeah let's
see if we was able to finish that in
style okay that was a strip um ski
against Robson in the position I think
that Maurice was sharing with us he was
mentioning the march of the h-bond as
being a very devastating undercutting of
blacks position and it happened and it
happened and there's five so with the
direct idea of checking the black king
and forcing it out now Queen B five a
very clever move you seen so many times
in this tournament how bringing the
Queen into the defense is often the only
way not to lose immediately right so
here the Queen h7 can you have a queen
h8 can be met by Queen g8 right and this
is how the game went this is how is
happen no Queen h4 are trying to nibble
the other way yeah Knight h7 is a
massive threat exactly and so in order
to get out of that what does he do
well maybe move his rook forward
rook c5 or rook d7 perhaps one of those
two moves in order to meet yes this
check exit stage right
the problem is you can take on e4 it's a
moment and it looks pretty ugly well
let's keep in mind for all of rays fans
ready yeah he does have an extra petrol
you can win this pawn on e4 as you just
mentioned
but there is an extra night but the
question is more about this King R is
his blacks king after a situation like
rook here actually I'll take it back
let's start with rookie 7 let's a little
safer yeah let's not take away what
might be a needed defense with the
Knight to e5 and let's imagine this
position for a second at first I think
Ray's doing ok I don't see this is being
am I missing something I don't see the
decisive a decisive lawyer know one
thing that is interesting is if white
could is allowed to simply play the move
Knight f7 the black Queen on g8 could
find itself imprisoned but otherwise at
the moment I don't quite funny funny
Queen trap indeed and then maybe it's
not and then if we put our queen on h7
you can just ignore it if you take it
back and we're gonna gonna make a queen
but so instead of instead of work take
t4 or how about we try your move Knight
a7 denied F opes excuse me let's go back
so after Queen here let's say oops I'm
sorry I get it okay yeah do your version
7 so we can try Knight f7 as you say and
I'm thinking that blacks king wants to
run over to safety King d7 and just kind
of hopscotch across the board
white could capture this pawn on e4
relatively speaking at any time why
don't we just start with that and maybe
the Queen should just kind of slide over
to the protection of the rook still
looks to me like it was anybody's game
so it looks like we've got a got a
continually mess here and it can end up
in our one of our favorite imbalances of
the tournament even in the rook first
two pieces if if black were to sacrifice
their work for the night
great seven because that was another
option as soon as I played NATO seven
you could have just snapped it off and
right trying to see how that looked
Jennifer I gotta bring us back to the
game between Anna and arena because that
not only is our key game in me I think
we'll decide the Women's Championship
for although it's so early that even
even if Irina on a wins theoretically
the other one could just like go on a
tear and you know make up for it it's
possible oh sure
so we do have this situation with Knight
takes f3 I was thinking that this was
the key move a little bit earlier but
fine you better late than never and this
move on a knight c8 I don't like that
that looks like an overreach there okay
the bishop just dropped back to the f8
square so that this pawn is protected on
d6 efficiently by Bishop and Queen it's
similar to the variation we were looking
at except that now if work takes g7
Queen g7 Knight takes d6 is possible so
that must have been one eye on how to
mind yes but why don't we recapture with
the King yes okay so that's the
difference you can recapture with the
King and now v is adequately defense
beef d6 rather is adequately defended
exactly so this is very good for arena
it looks very weird yeah this is how I
know what happened was oh pardon me
Bishop f8 yes Rocky Seven Kings e7
Knight b6 Bishop back to e7
so after Knights
she just realized that she was mistaken
maybe she hallucinate it and forgot that
Keeks g7 was possible she went back to
b6 where her Knight is now safe again
mm-hmm and I'm Rena replied with a
Bishop e7 maybe she's gonna get
something to the h4 square soon on a
pins her down with a queen g1 and you
just like black hair because blacks
pieces seem to be much better
coordinated I just like black here
because first she firstly she has to to
Bishop secondly it's White's King that
is being cornered not the black king
after a move for example like King h6
escaping the pin for a moment or perhaps
maybe even safer would be say King h7
keeping the square g8 and just preparing
maneuver like Knight h4 so I could play
Bishop g2 that some threats that White
has to be prepared to deal with and
maybe the initiative has swung in the
favor of Rena exactly in this moment
absolutely it's it's hard to miss a beat
in the Kings in the end now I don't know
we'll try to defend in this position for
instance maybe she'll play something
like night of to to harass the main
offender here that Bishop on h3 I see
yes indeed we have to do something we
can't just if we if we allow this night
h4 move I think it's gonna be a bust oh
well and in fact that move might have to
simply excellent because the bishop has
no safe squares to retreat to back along
the diagonal so Knight f2 would
definitely put the kibosh on that the
move Queen g1 is therefore a very sly
little move by ana remember Maryse was
pointing out those retreat who's that
and winning material well I just fell
for one I mean you know that was a
that's that's a pretty threat and we do
a couple more moves in the games and you
might want to upload and we have it
looks like after after night okay
instead of your move of king h6
she played Bishop to d8 attacking the
knight so Knight f2 would of course be a
terrible blunder because Bishop takes p6
so Knight c4 and again keeping up her
attack against the d6 pawn bishop c7
simple defense in this case what arena
has done is emitted she's made it
possible for her to retreat her or he's
a man yeah am bishop he won so white
releases her assault against the d6 pawn
because she wants to protect against the
near future Knight h4 so she played
bishop he won and now and now it's a
Rena I think more moves have been played
okay and it looks like yeah these two
are playing pretty quickly and we are in
the end of the hour here it looks like
Irina's 46 seconds according to the
official website wow you guys chess
champs calm / live I just got about over
4 and they've got 4 moves to make here
wow so this is extremely tense and it
looks like we got 90 for Bishop c7 what
else has happened key one Kevin Bishop
you won king f7 so getting out of the
pin and now knight h4 could be in the
menu again except now this bishop is is
guarding that square anyone so what's
going on here and you were talking about
how earlier in the game arena was kind
of removed easygoing now if you look at
the webcam and you see the intensity now
both ladies are locked in focused and
honest showing a little bit more tension
than their opponent even though she has
more time now we're gonna go right back
to this game but first let's take a look
at Robson with Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley well Jenn we all know the feeling
that after a game you think you've
played really well and then somebody
points out to you usually some Joker
that you missed a vicious tactic also
the computer does this to you to you I
play this many times where I go back to
the
thinking I did something great put my
moves in and turns out that I didn't
find the best moves and in fact didn't
find a move that I would have been
extremely proud of well sierpinski had a
move for the ages that he missed when
you see this you're going to not believe
it
he had this attacking position where he
had sacrificed a piece for the attack
and he played correctly with the move
Queen to h8 check and Queen to g8 and
right at this moment it looks as though
the queen is under attack it needs to
back out but in fact he had an
incredible Queen sacrifice simply with
the move rook takes e4 and now if Queen
takes Queen then Knight 8:7 check and
the King cannot move over because of
rook takes rook check mate game over but
in this position after Knight to h7
check if you play Queen takes on 87
white throws in rook takes rook check
forcing the King to capture and after
pawn takes Queen that pawn is going to
promote to a lady and it's lights out it
turns out stripper skis still winning
but I think he would have been really
proud to finish off this game in this
fashion Jenny yes wow what a beautiful
variation I love in some tactics books
they have a chapter on pawn promotion
and there's usually several positions
related on that and just stunning to
really see it in a game a very artistic
finish and nice nice nice catch
unfortunately again by the computer
missed by the human oh that would have
been a beauty Emma agree you know the
nice thing about chess is that a lot of
the beauty is in the variations and
that's why it's great that we're able
here to to comment on and show some of
that because sometimes the most gorgeous
variations aren't actually played with
Anna's economy and Irina crush we are
really more in the time scramble mode
where Irina has less than 55 seconds now
we should point out there's a 30 second
increment so she's not gonna lose on
time unless she freezes it does happen
it does yeah 30 second bonus each time
the players complete their move press
their clock they are awarded the Fisher
bonus of 30 seconds per move now in this
position where the where I think it it's
terribly imbalanced to to bishops for
for black Bishop F to was played by the
way Bishop F to was played i ron't
Irina's 55 seconds ticking down and she
did play a move it looks maybe like 9 H
4 I'm thinking she's playing 94 I'm not
sure what she played we'll find out
momentarily
okay and I think she I think we are and
moved 39 now we did play Knight h4 by
the way and that move sets up a
devastating threat that has to be
addressed Bishop g2 Shaq would win
whites Queen so I think I think honors
intention is to play Knight to e1 which
both defends the f3 pawn while
protecting against the check on g2 yes
and I think we have seen those moves on
the board actually okay so 91 was played
and now we're on move 39 so just two
moves left for Irena to make time
control and chill a little bit
go get some tea well I tell you nothing
feels better and in the world of chess
when you've made the time controlling
you can get up and take a break take a
breather because your hearts been
pounding at an incredible rate for the
last little while there by the way again
b5 by the way I mean about B fight by
arena the game between gada and Larry
has exploded it's like wild stuff again
I don't even know how blacks poem got to
g2 I think we should go to Maurice and
has asked him if he thinks it's
something decisive has occurred on board
whan between the you know number
one-ranked gata Kamsky the
pre-tournament favorite in Boston zone
Larry
battling Kristensen yeah and I think
Maurice is cueing that up and it seems
like meanwhile in our top board for the
Women's Championship they are just about
to make time control so we will see how
that goes I mean it does seem like
things after tan control might peter out
while i think it's the activity of
blacks pieces is to be preferred and
that decides the constant crush game I'm
not sure it's gonna be enough without
works on the board
with so many trades I like black alright
and here we go with Maurice well before
I get to the gotta calm ski game it
turns out ray Robson who looked dead in
the water
is now back in the game making an
incredible turn of events let's go to it
we saw earlier this position where
serpents key had that fantastic finish
and we all know when we're in time
pressure what happens you start playing
quickly just flub it you make some bad
moves and that's it well in this
position here Alistar [ __ ] should have
dragged his Queen back off of this
square but instead he went for a tactic
he thought was good and he played Knight
to f7 and after rook takes on g6 he
thought hey I'm winning the Queen here
with rook check King takes and rook
takes Queen
but after Knight takes he gets a look at
the position and think wait a minute
the guy's got a rook a knight too
working two nights for my queen and now
white is no longer winning so Robson
somehow pulled off this miracle and time
pressure and he's back in the game so
the Robson fans have to be thrilled that
this happened now going to the other
game this explosion we talked to that
you talked about guys it looks as though
the computer thinks the game is slightly
better for white only slightly we'll
have to play the moves through to see
what is actually going how this actually
occurred but right now it looks as
though black is fine and the game should
end should end in a draw but who knows
we've seen a lot of stuff happened here
at these championships jet and yes well
I just have to see how they do that
Jenna I'm not sure who I Wow Larry and
gotta evening up I thought that I can't
imagine how there's white that pardon me
how this black pawn managed to worm its
way to the g2 square this is like a
salmon swimming upstream
now I'm say we have some breaking
results coming in and this is a the time
of the day where blood is spilled Jorge
is a Jorge some more has been beat Marco
no that's his first victory of the event
Alexander shavelev moves to 2-1 with a
win over two
year-old Samsa beyond mean shaba daba
and and alexander own Ashok has won
against Ben Feingold and we had looked
at that game earlier and you you quite
liked ownership side just aesthetic
Queen's Gambit edge so he explored that
through and now climbs two-to-one okay
when the number three seats showing why
he was one of the tournament
pre-tournament favourites this is a
position we just want to go back a move
or two this is a position that we had
more or less left it between gada Kamsky
white the number one seed in the
tournament versus Larry Christianson we
got to a position like this Larry went
for f4 Knight f1g to rook takes d4 and
now we see how that pawn magically
arrived on the g2 square that's amazing
Knight e3 Bishop to c5 nice attack
against the rook bishops looking good at
the moment this work on a1 isn't working
let's see how God a continued rook G for
Shaq to the black King King retreated in
the corner and now knight c6 makes sense
bringing the knight into play with a
gain of a tempo against the room rook
takes d5 so Larry tossing out an
exchange sacrifice Knight takes d5 and
black the plate and the computer thinks
that white stands only a smidgen better
after the best move Bishop takes d5 this
is what the computer considers the best
move then it's natural to bring the
knight back into play Knight to be for
attacking this pawn on d5 and the
computer reckons that with this pawn on
g2 protected by backed up by the bishop
on d5 white is only slightly better well
we keep seeing these two bishops
throughout the championship and
imbalances galore I'm speaking of a man
who
never shiz from an imbalance we have
Grandmaster Alexander table of who now
has two victories after losing his first
round game de gata Kamsky and he is with
Maurice we lovingly call him Shabba and
he's with me now Alexander cheval off
hailing originally from Latvia from the
Latvian school of we don't like your
king a chess Shabba congratulations on
your win today thank you
what was it like playing a 12 year old I
mean he's a little guy well not exactly
he's a real his a sensation of this
tournament and it's not the first time
I'm playing him so I know him a little
bit I know he's extremely tough I've
seen him win in our World Championship
in Maribor in Slovenia so believe me I
was dead serious
and so the opening was like very
balanced equal position in the middle
game and then he went out to this point
on a four it allowed me to create an
attack which was not that clear but he
was like in a severe time trouble and
that threat to theta may indeed that's
very tough now you lost your first game
and I mean zero one is not the greatest
way to start a tournament although
you've done it before and come back in
one I've seen you do it and then in the
second game you are dead in the water
against Zamora husband I mean it looked
like it was all over but the crying and
somehow you pulled off a victory even
and now you've won today I mean what
what you got some lucky rabbit's foot er
I didn't know that that's exactly what
happened a couple years ago here when
after couple of losses I was dead law
dead lost against melech ha Chang and I
was like even more dead than I was
against Jorge and somehow I pulled out
the win which was the beginning of my
like finish like I don't remember what I
scored like four and a half out of five
so I mean well the loss against gateau
was like a heart you know people just
appeal to swallow because I was so much
better after the opening and
just allowed him to get you know out of
equal position and then it was just like
you know one way straight I mean he
played fantastic game and yesterday well
what can I say
it happens that the professional
attitude right it happens you just got
to play the next game
absolutely yeah I mean hopefully I don't
know how for he's doing today but one
today actually Fanta yeah I mean he's
not the guy who's gonna cool it down out
yet I wanna say indeed so moving forward
you have two out of three any thoughts
about the next round
Oh we'll see it's just like come in I'm
glad you know I'm out of the the base
trouble yeah I'm out of the trouble out
of though we call the basement we call
it a girl's room all right with that
congratulations on your victory and best
of luck in the rest of the tournament I
hate to do it back to you yes and
probably a fuming Jennifer Shahadah I
never even heard that one me either but
I like it I hope it sounds better in
Russian well let's take a look at the US
Women's Championship
Anna's at on ski and Irene a crush have
just made time control all right and it
just as a shatalov was talking about the
boys the boys I was thinking about
sending that night on be six to the boys
room on a eight uh item B six as we just
cuz I love playing nineteen if I can
play 98 or night H one I'm always
looking for it
yeah what do you get where'd you pick
that up the night store as we as we say
the cold the cold and I'll ski specialty
yeah well I don't think 9a is really a
serious move I'm just like pretty upset
here about that night on b6 is it looks
like white pieces are a bit overworked
like everything's defending each other
right like that's right we've got our
night on you won defending f3 Angie
our queen is like hanging on by a thread
here we're hanging you on to our night
on v6 if we could get attacked another
time it would be goodbye right so I just
I'm feeling uncomfortable for right here
I feel like there's no more clear
weaknesses or way for black to increase
her edge but white is not feeling
comfortable here with that night just
hanging in there agreed on all counts
the problem is is you just very do
correctly described it it's hard to
bring any more firepower against the
night on b6 so that's fine my t8 would
probably lose to Bishop a5 for what it's
worth right I mean they KITT because if
we can remove that night only one it's
like it's really bad yes well that is
the one thing that Anna desperately
wants to avoid I mean you would have to
bail out with the debate four or
something but yeah we should age for
that doesn't that looks pretty ugly that
a bailout or impression anyway I don't
want to go there no maybe a four though
at some moment I mean but again right
now if you do it maybe black would just
snap off on a four and then play Bishop
a5 again so that could be irritating as
well exactly I'm thinking that what what
Anna might do is try to prepare that
move 84 with a move b3 followed by a
four so that she can cement her her
knight keep it well protected with a
pawn on a5 computer even though we agree
White's pieces are tied up it reckons
that arenas advantage is a smidgen Oh
interesting a lot of them specifically
good piranhas that she's made command
control because this is the type of
position you're in time pressure very
difficult to defend is why with the
extra 30 minutes she might be able to
hold on to all of her pieces yes yes and
you know she does not want to get fed to
the little boy's room right the little
boy's room oh I think you misheard I'm
sorry Jennifer let me help okay well we
do have another really exciting
interview on tap I do - I'm passing by
the way I don't think we mentioned that
Caden did
unfortunately the Greenfeld
did not survive against virus treatment
of h4 h5 we do have a result that
version of Cobian has one with white
against 14 year old Kaden trough some
Kaden trough started excellently but
doctors Board has lost two games in a
row but what an incredible experience it
is for these youngsters and I think
we're gonna be hearing more from them in
the rest of the tournament without
question and now we have another victor
from the US Chess Championship who is
down here to talk with Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley Lee Jen we are with Jorge
Zamora husband who I remember seeing as
like a 10 or 11 year old in the
now-defunct Manhattan chess club blitz
playing blitz against Jay Bonin
sacrificing pieces everyone knew he was
a tremendous talent and I've watched him
grow over the years congratulations on
your victory today oh thank you well
what is it like we saw the first game
you blended a piece OUP's against Kai
Donovan you didn't have to and then
yesterday you were just completely
crushing Shabalala and that was a loss
what is it like after those two rounds
to have to now think about playing today
and to having a clear mind well I mean
it's not easy because I think typically
when you when you're playing in and
you're pointing out plays here I think
you kind of feel good if you lose but
the game against Caetano if I mean it
was painful I mean I drop a piece in a
position that is subjectively equal and
again Chuvalo if I found like the best
way to lose so I started thinking how
much Italian are having screwing up
positions when I'm better and today I
almost did it again really today I mean
I got a free pulled out of the opening
and then and then I managed to give my
opponent a lot of country play well but
in the end you won or relief to be sure
what do you what do you do now I mean
you sound like you're down even after
this victory how you gonna get your head
back to play the rest of the tournament
it's little long way to go
well I mean can I even get worse I mean
I think like the worst thing already
happened to me you know I lost two games
and now whatever goes goes I mean it's
just a tough tournament I mean it's
whenever you drop half a point or
many nerds especially with this guys you
know I mean they don't give you anything
for free so every game is a fight so
like today I was just hoping not to lose
you know I was my goal I woke up this
morning I'm like not three and okay now
your first u.s. championship when you're
the tender age of 16 did you really did
you think that it would be this long
before you got back on the mat well I
didn't think it was gonna be that low
but somehow I think I did a lot better
back then than what I'm doing right now
so no I mean I'm actually happy that I
got the opportunity to play cool well we
wish you the best and hopefully you get
a clear mind for the rest of the
competition congratulations on today
thank you all right
well Jorge Zamora Rob's own husband
having won a game I know what that feels
like you know get your first victory
feels good have a good dinner Jen and
yes I think heart gauges it is with the
quote of the day I figured out the best
way to lose I hadn't heard that one
before in Seattle we seize the defensive
but figure out the best way to lose that
was very good I'm gonna use that as an
original by the way thank you for gay
where do we stand Jen where do you want
me to go show me the way we haven't
looked at the ivanov Shanklin game in a
while all right
and I'd also like to mention a result
I'm Elena katsu drew against had to have
a burn ha me on and Abraham Ian was on -
OH
Alena Katz has two drawers under her
about now and last year she only got one
and a half points out of the entire
tournament so one out of three
considering that she's played two of the
three favorites in the tournament she is
should I mean I'm not saying that she's
happy but she certainly poised to do
better than she did last year we got
Ivanov in Shanklin yeah this looks like
a Dasha scrappy affair but I you know
it's very funny these days I first I you
know count the material and I go well
Sam's got a extra pawn and then I kind
of look and see well where's the
compensation and I don't see it so
my first impression we're going to have
to go back a little ways but that Sam
Shanklin stands extremely well and is
well on his way to winning so a lot of
decisive games it feels like to me in
this round maybe I'm missing something
but everything seems to be going crazy
people aren't making safe sane draw
boring draws that my generation lived
upon but here we go looks great
entertained definitely sure and the last
move was rook
so rook c8 c4 imagine for a moment white
would to take this pawn bishop takes on
d7 holy cow looks like I'm allowing a
mate can you see the mate oh no just uh
just rook to you for it's a good
position exactly and then h3 after we
take on h5 we're actually protecting the
wreck with our bishop on e6 don't hate
that yes King takes d4 that's the kind
of move I try to make against my kids
and the lectures that I give and they go
no and I go I'm the Grandmaster I can
play King takes g4 and they go no you
can yeah but and then you teach the
Mamba sign and they really think you're
you're fiddling with them weird that's
it but here I'll tell you what young how
about a tricky one how about if we play
rook takes as a prelim can I hope to get
away with this grabbing or is it still
rotten mmm certainly looks dangerous
because we can still play work to you
for it but then after King age three we
have work h4 work do you wan and that
same threat that looks decisive doesn't
it
mean we would have to yeah looks like
the end hopeful we would have to play
king h2 but just go over here so this is
not picking up two new pawns
well we we do have another guest with us
in Grand Master Maurice Ashley's booth
grand master version of Cobian welcome
to the show guys
grand master version of Cobian with us
now we should mention that he has been a
multi time member of the Olympic team
one of the strongest grandmasters in the
u.s. somebody that people are pointed to
is maybe a favor to win this event as
well with the big boys congratulations
on your victory today thank you you've
drawn two games and won one how you
feeling about your start I feel fine I
had two too long games yesterday
especially my game was the latest to
finish about a team was against Ben
Feingold so it was a very long game I
was slightly better I tried to win but
you know he defended very well and this
start today you had to play against one
of the youngest players in the
competition everyone is gonna have to
face these young guys have you played
Kaden trough before no I never played
against him so first time what do you
think about this youth movement I mean
it seems like so many young players in
the championship this year I think it's
great it's I think it's a fantastic
opportunity for them to play in a US
Championship this year and experience
what is it like to play against the
grandmasters every game and the strong
strong grandmasters and and I know he's
very talented player and one of the u.s.
Junior World Youth Championships so when
I was preparing I tried to play
something new that I knew he didn't face
before so this age for move
I tried today it's a relatively a new
move
melosa which played and some other
grandmasters but it's not a much theory
but then he responded very well with the
c6 so we were following the group
crossing game and then when I play
Bishop g5 he played Queen b6 novelty so
he surprised you can you move yeah I
mean I looked at a lot of the lines and
Carlsen played castle in that position
but then II played couldn't b6 and I
didn't look at this move at all but I
spent about 20 minutes and I played the
way I thought I should play but I think
it was about tickle everything I had an
advantage yeah he played some really
interesting unorthodox ideas taking on
age five and and taking on c4 his
position got it seemed like he has some
chances what happened after that where
was this big mistake
I think position was about Tico and we
were wolf spending a lot of time in fact
I was bit worried because I didn't have
that much time left and position was
still unclear and then I think the
critical moment where he played he when
I played the nigth and he should have
just played Bishop h6 here and I think I
have to play a for Bishop takes g5f 65
and position is probably about equal but
then he played 97 and this might be a
big mistake because he overlooked he
told me Knight takes c6 96 Bishop g4
all right so 95 is Knight and that's I
think it's a top point it sort of just
loose all right so the fans of are out
there Knight g5 is that critical moment
when when instead of Bishop h6 he play
Knights he said 90 70 I was all right so
now it's time to move forward you
haven't lost a game you that can't feel
bad and you got two points out of three
what do you think about now about moving
forward in the tournament well I think
the tournament just started so at this
point it's just important to try to play
just well every game I mean there's some
people have more points but I think
there's still six more games to go and a
lot of things can change so I just have
to try to take one game at a time
professional attitude congratulations on
your victory today best of luck in the
rest of the tournament Grandmaster
virgin Akopian
off to a fine start having that not lost
the game as yet one of the favorites to
be at the top of the podium at the end
of the tournament Jenna yes thank you
nice of a nice victory by a Kobe in
there are far played very professionally
and as he said and I found very
interesting was trying to do something
to upset the youngster by playing
something very very fresh not much
theory h4 and then in turn getting
surprised himself with green be six hate
that when it happens like that I do but
a very interesting game we always like
to see people tear apart the Grune fell
on rather than sidestep it with c4 c3
things that some of the anti green
filters like to do
let's take a quick look at gray of
Benjamin because we shouldn't count out
Benjamin you know he came into this
round with one and a half points and you
know theoretically he could easily be
one of the tournament leaders after this
round
absolutely but he we haven't checked in
on him in a in a little while so let's
see how this game is going with tamargo
Rio well wouldn't we had open that is
kind of like an Enzo Indian where would
the move a three in Queen takes c3 white
wins the two bishops Joe likes these
types of positions we saw it in the game
between by the way Gary eV and Larry
Christensen where Larry gave up his two
is dark squared bishop and the players
were moving right along all very
standard lines of play for both sides
this move Bishop h3 by the way deserves
common the idea is that white would like
to preserve his two bishops white would
like to play 9k to but not allow the
trade of bishops yeah because you don't
want to get I mean the whole point is
you have the two bishops and your
opponent has a very solid position if
you give away the two bishops there's
your edge right so Bishop h3 seeking to
preserve the two bishops D 592 and Queen
f4 so here I prefer White's position
so our knight age five it's not that big
a deal yet I mean I'm not surprised with
this move C takes d5 I like keeping that
tension and I probably would have just
dropped back with my bishop that maybe
Gary I thought the bishop was actually
better on h3 so we get a position and
quite still nursing a small advantage
nothing special at the moment and we're
getting to we're playing catch-up to the
board position and I must admit that I
think whoa now for a moment there it
looked like there was a repetition and
joel avoided the repetition very
interesting right so he's on this
weakness here this this
can king position well he's thinking
that his Bishop and Knight and queen
make a better combination of pieces than
whites Bishop on b2 that has to say that
what white bishop on b2 is passive and
let's not forget that he was him
trolling the only open file on the board
although two more took it over with that
booth between c4 that we just saw
exactly now get him okay wait exposed
King black wanted no part of trading off
Queens especially since it would have
allowed two more to get a beautiful
Center with a be take c4 always a
critical moment in games when your
opponent offers you that Queen trade
right so now we we careful evaluation of
resulting endings you know I'm still I'm
somehow I would I like Joel's position I
can't for the King safety it's all about
the King safety wouldn't you rather be
blacks
I mean whites blacks King than whites
King although that's changed a little
bit with that Queen invading on d5 but
it looks like Queen d8 check type moves
can be decently met by King f7 but then
are there perps lurking perpetual is
looking just with a Queen d7 like how
are we really just marking that King off
the board no I think that what from
Joe's point of view what Joe would like
to do is after white lose his King I'm
not sure King g3 or King h3 let me just
take a quick look the computer actually
prefers Bishop d2 if I were in black
shoes I'd be very attracted to this move
Bishop efore so as you were mentioning
Jen I don't want to move my king to f7
rather to h7 so that's why I get that
Bishop out of the way and with the move
Bishop b4 by the way I invite I'm
inviting the trade of Bishops which
would leave White's King exposed right
and so the only thing you really have to
work watch out for in this type of
position is that pesky little h6 move
from timing checkmate on g7 and then
after Bishop f3 King takes f3 you're
gonna stop that checkmate ah okay with
Queen f5 this
you can't I mean you can't imagine that
night on d5 is just a monster you can't
get rid of its row but I mean you're
trying to win this oh gosh yes oh gosh
there's a hoops excuse me I was driving
but king takes that fine wow so you
think this is a this is plenty for black
well no I'm like I'm saying worth trying
definitely black takes absolutely no
risk in this ending maybe he doesn't win
it but he sure as heck has no chances of
losing it there's just no way he's going
to lose it and maybe if on a very very
sunny day is king my March now this is
your idea fan of each a see Arthur yes
exactly I was like a long King March you
see that look at those arrows boy good
luck with that
thank you that's the only way just like
with with our guest earlier John Bryan
you know you gotta aim high otherwise
you're never gonna win these like squeak
these little edges out so interesting
game here and it looks like a slight
advantage for Benjamin with the better
King position and he's really showing
his chops here in his 26th a US Chess
Championship and doesn't look like he
could have played in 26 US chess
champion jazz although I wonder how many
Semyon will have played mine uh oh my
gosh well that's great so we're gonna
take a quick break here from the US
Chess Championship and we'll be right
back with the exciting conclusions of
our games today
you
hello and welcome back to our 2013 u.s.
test championship coverage I'm Jennifer
Shahaji I'm here with Yasir Sarah Juan
and we are closing in on round three are
two key matchups
Ana's at on skeevers Irina crashed in
the women's on we we certainly like
black but how for her to push forward
what we've been wondering for the last
30 minutes to an hour and did Irina come
up with an idea the last we checked they
just made time control right these were
the last few moves be 596 Queen b8 and
we mentioned how White's pieces the
Queen on Jiwon bishop on f2 are tied to
the defense of the night on b6 and I
really think that this is really crunch
time on the round this is the third
fourth fifth hours this is where it's
not just mental calculation and ability
but also physically to maintain these
high levels of energy you need
throughout the entire round so we're
really down to the wire here a bit
before I didn't like because that does
not help white rescue her night I
thought B three and a four was required
she played B or you could play a four
and then after night a for Bishop 85 93
that's like another possibility I'm
sorry you could have also played a four
directly and if B takes a four you could
recapture and then after Bishop a5 you
know head on back with the Knight c3 and
that might not be the end of the world
so this was kind of the other
possibility to rescue the night but the
pawn on b2 becomes another potential
target okay working on my errors here
Queen B something better than Queen b6
there you have it but what on the one
hand two on the kingside these pieces
look really nice but there wasn't a real
way for arena to take advantage so she
actually just retreated her Knight right
perhaps this releases her Queen
from the defense of the night and maybe
allows her one day to advance her h-bond
again this White's King in the corner
it's discomforting to me at least to
figure out where the where the pieces
are going to invade so we're gonna be
keeping a close eye on this game and III
have to say it looks like time birch was
gonna become a problem again because
it's been about 20 minutes it's time
control even more probably probably
about 30 minutes and they've only made
one month well he hasn't my time travel
might rear its ugly head here's a
thought from blacks point of view how do
you like this isn't a concept just as a
concept mind you so you have to make a
move with white gents so we just say a
threefold moment just here here's the
thought that was floating around my
noggin is this idea that because our
night has dropped back it helps protect
our King
but with this move Queen c8 I've
released my queen so I can invade with
idea of grabbing pawns and that looks
very unpleasant you see yeah she's gonna
have to really squirm squirm to to get
out of that you know she can't let
everything happen at once well as we
seen kind of pretty variations even on
the horizon like I'm imagining Queen
takes II one Queenie one Bishop DG to
check and Knight takes f3 right there
it's just like there are waves for
blacks position to just harmonize and
bring in a potential victory but again I
think time pressure is going to be an
issue it's been one move since I'm
control and they both use what looks
like twenty minutes I don't understand
it's a critical position and they've
probably been looking into the horizon
to see what's gonna come but I still
think that's a very impractical decision
right okay I
I'm liking arenas position more and more
I always thought that this Bishop on h3
was going to be monstre Bishop miss
turned out to be the case and in time
pressures certainly could be harder for
honor to play now we have another victor
from the Women's Championship
Irina's ENIAC who lost Irena Cross
yesterday one today against Victoria
knee and now has two points and she is
with Maurice Ashley did Irina Xenia
congratulations on your victory today
thank you
how'd you feel about the game I thought
I had a comfortable edge for the whole
game and then we both got into a time
travel and there is like scramble heaven
and they're like all this crazy
variations but I managed to come with
decisive advantage after that time
scramble you're mentioning that it seems
like a common theme in this tournament
everybody's going to time pressures like
scramble City here is it something about
the the time control that's causing this
I think partially right but I think also
because it's such a high stakes games
and preparation and just want to figure
out what's your or where your opponent
wants you to go to and it takes time
actually yeah now Jen mentioned that you
lost your good friend arena crush
yesterday what is it like playing
against such a great friend of your she
she said you were probably her best
friend in the world
that's must be tough that's saying for
me actually when I play it's very hard
because I really like need that
determination almost like anger against
my opponent to play a while but against
Irena I mean she's my best friend I
cannot do that she's just and I'm
rooting for her in this tournament too I
really want her to win too
right so it was hard but well she flies
really well yesterday so I can't blame
and now you're a 2 out of 3 you know you
know maybe there are two clear favorites
in this tournament as we see but two out
of three is nothing to sneeze that what
do you feel about your chances your
chances to win the tournament I'll take
one game at a time as Irena said all
right indeed well congratulations on
your victory today and wish you the best
in further games
he knows Enya on two out of three great
score to start the tournament back to
you Jenny yes great to hear from Irina
then you and every time I see
Irina she seems to be smiling and it is
a her yourself
exactly this is it's good to have fun
when you're playing jest especially you
know she has a engineering career or
outside chess so for her probably you
know analyzing 20 moves deep is actually
easier it's a break it's a mental break
your imagine well we do have a big
result in halt has defeated on Ramirez
and that means that Conrad Hall has got
two and a half points my good you give
up there with John Bryant Grandmaster
Conrad Hall also has two and a half
points just like John Bryan and if
Kamsky does not win today they will be
tied for the lead yeah rather if the
game between Kamsky and Kristensen is
not decisive well as Maurice was
mentioning Alejandro he went for with
with the Banco gambit is black gambling
material in order to attain an early
initiative but he obviously you must
have got outplayed later in the game I'm
still mesmerized by the way to everybody
on the first table first board we have
the game between Dada Kamsky and Larry
Kristensen both players are undefeated
perfect scores we have a of an exchange
up for gotta camp ski which is usually
decisive and in fact Larry doesn't even
have a pond Descamps position but he has
these fabulous two bishops and the
computer is not giving white the big
advantage that you would expect from
being an exchange up let's go to this
game and see what it happened players
have reached this
point and this is where Larry's bishop
came to that nice square f3 keeping that
f2 pawn whites-only passed pawn in the
position stuck on its original Square
and we have a check and I'm pretty much
expecting the move king c2 here and now
you just have to be careful not to allow
these checkmates this would be a
horrible move of course to allow room to
be a chakram made there from White's
perspective he would love to play rook
f4 with that double threat of the back
rank mate as well as attacking the
bishop so perhaps a move like route back
to f6 to just maintain that bishop on f3
and well now the computer likes the
position a little bit more for white it
looks to be a tough technical grind in
my view and it's the type of position
that gada loves the technical play still
I just don't see exactly let me see why
the computer things is so good for it's
an endgame so sometimes in these types
of end games it's calculations on it is
to be trusted as in the tactical melee
is well yeah it's very interesting it
reckons that it's because of this move
rook g5 that White's white angles for a
rook f5 trading and I guess the computer
is not afraid of losing this f2 pawn
because once again with the knight on f5
there is that rook b8 check and mate
concept so in other words well I just
need to make a move
let's say I made a move like this we get
this position this is what I'm saying
that he can't grab this pawn on f2
because the King is still made it at the
back rank you're not going after just
wanting a piece with rook afar
when we going after the veces Rekha for
so this is why the computer the computer
reckons that there's Bishop on f3 which
is an excellently place cannot be
maintained due to this rook g5 - f5 idea
and that's correct
well to be fair the computer doesn't
really think it's plugged in and answer
well we are gonna be continually keeping
an eye on this Kamsky Christianson game
and we do have a big winner in the USS
Championship in addition to John Bryant
who climbed to score two two and a half
with a win over Gregory Caetano of
Conrad Hall has defeated grandmaster
Alejandro Ramirez to jump up into the
same group two and a half out of three
and he is with Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley to talk about his victory thanks
Jen well 19 year old Grandmaster Konrad
Holt with two and a half points out of
three defeating Alejandro Ramirez today
congratulations on your result did you
expect to see a Banco gambit today I
mean Evancho is one of those sharp
opening sacrifice upon the guys trying
to beat you usually when he plays it I
mean I didn't really expect it I mean
he's played tens of bingo games it's and
he like you know made a DVD about it and
stuff
I thought you know he might avoid it
because you know I was gonna be prepared
and I thought you know maybe he wants to
play it you know more against opponents
who have no time to prepare or like
lower rated so I was a little bit
surprised it actually played in so when
he did did you feel comfortable on the
opening you felt your preparation was
sound yeah yeah so then at some point it
seemed like the game turned very sharp
very near the end and and all of a
sudden it was over I thought it was
gonna be a little bit more of a fight
did you think what what happened
actually at the end did he just blunder
or what happened I mean I guess after
Queen c4 it seems like I should probably
win pretty quickly so I mean I guess he
should have moved his king somewhere
other than f7 ICC he lined up his king
well you're one of the youngest players
in the tournament it seems like there's
been a real youth movement in
event we've seen John Bryan who's not as
young as you are but he's doing really
well at two-and-a-half or were your
expectations coming into the event this
is your first US Champion as well all
right yeah yeah I didn't have very high
expectations you know because I mean I
distracted by working on these final
exams that I've got another collegiate
where do you go to school University of
Texas at Dallas that's right okay
so you didn't prepare much at all we've
seen a lot of the collegiate players go
down in flames having not prepared for
this tournament how are you holding up
wondering I'm still having some time to
prepare you know for a couple of hours
at least and you know but maybe it's you
know just a good thing that I'm not just
sitting there analyzing for like five
hours straight or something so now
you're sitting at two and a half out of
three are you thinking you could win
this whole thing maybe no sorry I'll
start blundering at some point Wow I
doubt I'm not usually very consistent
well you are a grandmaster you got two
and a half points we expect great things
of you ready off to a fantastic start so
congratulations
thank you Grandmaster Conrad a 19 year
old hope for American chess doing really
well
back to genin yes Wow it sure feels good
at two-and-a-half half I tell you
playing in a US Championship scoring
that heavily it is youth American chess
is looking very very good very promising
we've got a generation of really superb
talent and Conrad impressing me yes and
it's it's interesting to see is
diametrically opposed the response to
the question of you know how do you
think you're gonna do the truth is that
there are many different psychological
approaches at work and there are some
people who feel that you know being too
optimistic can put too much pressure on
you then if you do lose you get really
upset and it's better just to even have
low expectations now that's rare usually
the opposite approach works a little
better but whatever works for people
exactly what
and as we get a grandmaster drill
Benjamin set up let's peak again at the
Akatsuki crush game because something a
little strange that I don't think we
predicted has happened in that game on
something else at Hunt he ended up with
her Bishop 195 okay which doesn't seem
like a good square it was just we had
left it the players had made their time
control and we did see this idea I
mentioned Jen which was to capture this
Knight and then just with this sly
little move Queen c8 what black is
intending to do is break down here an
invasion so I was trying to fight back
maybe with an invasion of her own some
counter play here when she pleases the
move Bishop to a5 one of the points is
that she may be able to start some
checks of her own but that being said it
better be a perpetual if she's gonna go
for it because Queen f1 if the Queen
strays too far will just be checkmate
precisely so I don't think those
perpetual checks are really going to
exist especially Knight will be able to
block in right I mean if we just for
example just trot our king over here to
the h6 where there's no more checks that
Knight is a great defender and as you
mentioned you can't allow Queen f1 so we
can't stray to try to to nibble in the
d6 pawn I'm so definitely come back yeah
yeah definitely a dominant position with
for Irina but that being said it still
seems like Anna's trying to hold it
together and both with fewer than five
minutes left on the clock
just six moves after time controls been
reach so we're gonna see them play this
interesting position on the thirty
second increment and now let's move over
to a grandmaster joel benjamin who is
off to a good start in the US Chess
Championship has two out of three and he
is with Grandmaster Maurice Ashley well
a real veteran of these US Championships
Grandmaster Joel Benjamin has played in
26 of them amazing amazing and you've on
how many three three you've won three
well congratulations on your drawer to
a thank you you started off pretty
solidly you haven't lost a single game
so far in the event what do you think is
that the secret to playing well at the
US Championship I mean you you've been
at 26 of them well I've done it for the
most part in the US Championship it gets
tougher when you get older and you have
children and you have to teach and do
things for money and you don't get to
spend as much time as you like working
on your own game so it's a little
apprehensive coming here but I'm very
relieved to get off to a good start and
I played a very tough field already the
second and third ranked players in the
event so I'm very pleased how it started
so far now you mentioned getting older
we received the championship getting
younger there's like a youth movement
going on we have 12 year olds playing in
the tournament I mean that just never
happened before what do you feel about
these youngsters that are playing well
let me tell a little personal story when
I when I set the record for most
consecutive US Championships played in
yeah the rec old-time record which was
23 comin but it was something like 15 or
16 when it was one or two set when I
when I got the record I was something
like this second youngest player in the
field after playing in all those Wow so
in the old days it would just be a lot
of old men and thankfully that's turned
around and this year it's very
interesting because we're finding that
some of the young stars that we know
about you know like like Ray Robson and
and Sam Franklin you know now they're
having trouble with these new guys who
have just arrived on the scenes
incredible so I do they're the older
generation of youngsters you go from
being the hunter to the hunted very
quickly indeed and you play two more
garea today a second ranked player you
played a 33 board syme old a blindfold
cyma before playing in this tournament I
doubt that's a recipe for winning for
preparing for us championship well it
certainly shows he's got a photographic
memory because he lost I think four
games in the Simon and I don't think
that I could play four games blindfold
at the same time let alone win all the
other ones but yeah he's a very tough
player I I've never played him before
I've only actually even been in one
tournament with him
and he certainly isn't it's an
interesting character the main thing
about the about the game today and what
I was most afraid of was the fact that
he played very fast in the opening he
had a huge lead on the clock and that
was what concerned me that I might make
a mistake running low on time otherwise
my position was pretty okay most of the
way now we're seeing that happen a lot
in this tournament players are getting
into time pressure time and time again
blundering pieces in decent looking
positions what is up with this time
control is this a problem for the
players well I can speak for myself I'm
a slow player you know I I just don't
make decisions efficiently as
efficiently as I should I hedge a little
bit too much and I know that to play to
another love what I have to play faster
but it hasn't been so bad so far to me
the real issue is after the first time
control when you get you get 30 minutes
on your clock plus the increment for the
rest of the game and sometimes the game
is not really clarified that much and
you're still in a very complicated
position sometimes after the first time
control you want to take 20 minutes on
the next move just to figure it out and
you can't you got hit the ground running
after that first time control and play
quick moves it's really difficult indeed
well you've manages so far so so well
you've got two out of three what do you
feel about your chances moving forward
in the competition well I feel pretty
good I think that you know gotta camp
skis ahead is a heavy favorite here but
beyond beyond him I think you know I my
chances could be as good as anyone else
as long as I'm I'm in good form I'm
getting enough rest and feeling good and
who knows what could happen well we hope
the best for you and the rest of your
games congratulations on your zalta day
thank you very much Maurice three-time
US Champion veteran of 26 of these
events and I should add a native New
Yorker Joel Benjamin back to you Jenny
yes thank you
does that give you an edge being a
native New Yorker yeah although I lived
it for
many years mm-hmm I Philadelphia in New
York it's kind of the next borough they
say an hour and a half away from a
friend to be the Big Apple but I think
Jill made a very interesting point there
is that even after you made the time
control you still have these very very
complex positions and you've only got 30
minutes with the bone is to make your
decisions and we're seeing let's move
right let's move back to that actually
although actually we have they're also
putting a Kamsky and Christiansen on the
webcam which is another game we have to
keep an eye on but whoa dude this really
just happen Knight g4 yes
so Queen g1 check followed by Knight g4
what's up with that
I think there was some issues with
Bishop d8 if if King h6 was played so we
had I was thinking about a little bit of
counter play going on therefore why
exactly let's think we should put maybe
move to the final position and so this
is where we were before right we had
that threat of queen f1 check as you
remember because we're both they're both
down two minutes here Wow
so Queen came back to stop the check 19
to EV six Queen check so clearly Anna is
hoping for repetition hoping for a
perpetual check arena says no juicy 94
g4 very very nice move so what's so if
if Anna doesn't take that doesn't if she
doesn't the night looks like it's gonna
be headed to e3 or maybe no no no no I
guess I I mean I would just play Queen
e2 with the idea of Knight f2 and that
would just be brutal so she'll be she'll
be compelled to take it after that move
at a certain moment there's no way you
can deliver the knight on g4 agreed so
taking on g4 seems-seems right and now
this is brutal to have to deal with in
time pressure like whoa every those
plants are coming at her and the e4 pawn
is hanging and it looks like they played
some moves Irina looks like she's got a
few minutes left on her clock and Anna
down to just a couple minutes all right
and it's looking pretty dire here
has captured on g4 Knight g4 captures
Queen captures efore look I beg your
pardon
Queen captures efore check has been
played and you heard me harping on the
fact that this King was stuck in the
corner this has become a serious
liability Knight g2 only moved to block
the check and now oh boy there's the
simple the human move is just to take
here but the reality is there's also
ideas like f3 allowing knight h4 i don't
know if we want to allow Knight h4 and
queen f2 maybe so yeah taking on g4 oh
honey probably irina ice has a number of
options here it looks like this this 94
moon was was the killer that Ayane might
have might have missed yes I don't see
exactly how she could have prevented it
however if your opponent moves your
moves for a knight around in place for
g4 this looks like a killer attack for
arena crush defending champion this
would this would be a big statement you
know Irina crush coming into the
tournament with a grandmaster
performance a couple months ago and
Ana's at on ski saying that she's
actually not been playing that well
recently that she's dropped some rating
points you know usually Ana is slightly
higher rated than Irina and I think in
this tournament Irina came in just a few
points higher rated so perhaps angry is
now just really vying for that top spot
no doubts about it this is it this is
and again it's physical preparation and
everything that this is where the points
are scored in this the fourth and fifth
hour of play because you just get tired
and your mind has been ramping up at so
many rpms for so long and I think the
position is just bad just plain bad for
Ana as she's struggling desperately
searching for a way out of her
difficulties that this pin is
devastating to begin with and finally
also just another pawn to be captured
I'm supposing a move like Queen f2 just
to try to escape this terrible pin would
be most likely and let's see did she
play it she has played Queen f2 and now
black to play I mean would you be
tempted I sure would just to capture
nibbling and make it yeah I just just
just keep nibbling why not right well I
mean and then you're you're threatening
and then you're threatening just Queen
d1 Czech followed by Queen g1 Bishop g2
and a pretty little smothered mate bear
with Queen f3 can we put that on the
board
okay so we're saying Queen takes d5 and
then just play like I guess play well
not don't ruin it just play like Bishop
d8 or something yeah to attack this pawn
and you're you have spotted to checkmate
yes I just like showing these pretty
little mates reminds me of something we
looked at the other day Jennifer do the
honors and now we have Queen to f3 with
the unusual smothered mate the Queen on
g1 stopping at stopping the King from
escape exactly no squares for the King
to run that's just that's just a that's
just one thing though but after after
Queen takes d5 you're just also making
it easy for yourself it's true that the
computer might find other lines that are
even quicker but when you just keep
taking off all the pawns you know that
probably almost every move is gonna win
at some point I mean this is just
indefensible for our Ana's at on ski and
she's just going down this game 100%
right I would agree I'm expecting King
Jiwon and here's one just to make it a
clean technical take out if you even
just trade everything and then you play
with these three pawns against this
Bishop I think that is also likely to
bring victory these pawns March like
ants up the board and I don't see
exactly how white could ever stop them I
don't think she can
Oh Arina crush winning with the black
pieces fantastic victory fantastic
victory in and moving herself to 3-0 and
I I expect that we will see a very
smiling Irina crush coming down here
soon
question for you yes if if I'm just
saying and don't think it's gonna happen
if arena crush was to score a perfect
result against the field is there a big
bonus no it's for the it's for the US
Chess Championship I think the the the
differential in skill strength in the
women's it would be far more likely I
mean we do have scores like you know we
had eight and a half one year and it's
eight the other year so I don't even
know I don't think it would be that I
think probably it's almost like 50 times
more likely to happen in the women's
like probably in the championship it
must be like a fraction of a percent in
the women's I wouldn't be surprised if
it's like three percent chance okay but
that's just that much manhood I mean
there was plenty of tough players in
there but it's pretty clear that Irene
on on are are this are the top dogs in
the section and uh we're getting the
better in this game and a very very nice
opening choice by Irina Queen takes d5
West played and we do have this as the
last move Queen see to check to the
black King arena just dropped back with
her king and the King to g7 and said
deal with my threats my threat of to
grabbing this knight on g2 and I think
that's all she wrote I don't one more
check for the road but that would be
about it Jack King age six you've got to
come back and defend the night and then
that liquidation idea would be good
enough the players are moving
I mean this game does look in the bag
though so let's take a look at our other
key game of the day between gotta Kamsky
and Larry Christensen well God has made
tremendous headway when we left it
Maurice and I had been talking it over
with Rexy
well it wasn't easy at all
for gada to make the most out of his
exchange when we left it we left it in a
position like this and gada I tell you
he's such a great technical player he
really put the pressure on Larry and
managed to trade rooks that was a big
technical accomplishment now gada can
concentrate with his own past pawn Larry
is not going down without a fight
he played h5 Knight jumped to d5 and
this is how things have progressed
notice how oh god it took the time to
bring his King all the way across the
board just to keep this little criminal
over here on h4 under lock and key
93 came back defending the bishop Knight
f5 that's a big move pawn is defended
but now it's under a double attack
Bishop f6 and got it to play the
computer considers White House as having
an advantage of two point two eight
pawns well yeah usually decisive I'm
afraid to say for fans of larry
christensen i include myself when i say
that material material counts doesn't it
yeah so gata Kamsky if he wins this game
will be three oldfield and looking out
for that uh that Fischer $64,000 prize
absolutely well I the the move that
makes the most sense to me rook a4
strangely enough is only the second
choice of the computer I would for sure
bang out this move we're okay for with
the double threat of attacking the pawn
on a7 as well as this pawn on h4 and I
think that white is well on his way to
victory after this move rook
for very very nice and we also have a
result Shanklin a one against one his
game against Ivanov so Sam Shankly and
not off to the best start in this
tournament but did win with black
against Ivanov who's a great
theoretician a nice and again sorry Jen
to go back to the game oh no no brother
one go back to our big game here that we
do have oh dear work' it's only for was
bang down bishop d5 came before so
obviously gada is eyeballing that pawn
on a seven and they're moving quickly
sure six rook a six how's that that's a
nice move trying to get rid of one of
those bishops why not lined up and I me
and I it looks like king f7 allows all
sorts of pesky checks including just
grabbing the pawn with Jack including
King so have they played king f7 I see
that from the webcam that they've got
some moves that have been played yeah
God has been playing quite quickly as
had and king f7 was made and then it
looks like it looks like rookies rook
takes a seven and 97 Jack played very
good and we got this position is Larry
responded to the 97 check he's about to
move his king
I believe you played King g5 and yeah
just uh this beep on now ready to roll
check are they playing so quickly you
think this is a bit unusual maybe
they're playing so quickly just because
Larry doesn't really feel like resigning
but wants to get a few moves in and the
game is over and it looks like got a
Kamsky 3-0 in the u.s. chess
championship interesting game there by
Kristensen but slipped up a couple times
a couple of two times many for our top
seed in the tournament gotta well I
think the critical moment was pegged
early by Maurice when he mentioned
Larry had this beautiful pair wet with
his night it was just after gada had
played the Mooji for which weakened the
f4 square and Larry could have played
Knight d4 back to knight c6 to d4 and
Knight d4 back to e6 and I like Larry's
position exactly at that moment he
missed that one moment yeah it's like
these guys these world-class
grandmasters they only give you one
moment in each game and once you've
missed that opportunity I think Larry
was just taken out well it's interesting
that you say that because it seems like
gotta gave the Knight d5 opportunity in
the game against truth and then the 94
game and the other run and and let's
check on Ana's at on ski and Irina crush
with Maurice Ashley oh we are actually
gonna take it ourselves on as a tan ski
and Irina crush here we go okay what's
going on here when we when we last left
it was this mom Irina snagged a pawn on
d5 and it was Queen c2 Czech Queens did
you check King G seven bishops e7 and
arena played f4 f3 with a devastating
threat of capturing this night and she
couldn't move her night because check
you're the one who likes check checkmate
so much so is the checkmate that black
could execute after night rule so just
play f2 here
sacrificing the Queen did your Queens
attack go ahead and take it and now I
would like to make a rock radically
promotion and now the material does not
matter check and mate the black white
queen and we've actually got a got a
camp ski here in in the studio 300
result and we're gonna get him set up
and hear from our front runner at the US
Test Championship who is wearing the
color of the day purple so and we do
have a situation where Arena has one
arena is also the game is over
yes crush the taunts key also over so
Irina crossed joining gata Kamsky with
Rio and looks like they're the only two
three O's in in the events impressive
both players know both players number
one seeds they've they've earned that
title moniker as the best in us chess
all right and now let's i/o and we're
gonna take a quick quick tweet from an
audience member from Zack Haskin who
points out that round three isn't over
and my bracket is already shattered he's
referring to fantasy chess my roommate
who barely plays chess is crushing me
maybe 2014 hashtag us chess champs this
reminds me of all the all the sports
fans a lot of a lot of male sports fans
who get their their girlfriends to sign
up for the NCAA polls and the
girlfriends will always win as you know
yeah the woman's touch and here we go
with we got a got a camp ski and Maurice
Ashley and we are here with our only
perfect score in the men's event gata
Kamsky sitting at 3a no congratulations
on your victory
okay got it this was this looked like a
tough game how did you manage to pull
this out okay that's not a fair question
I mean we both played and we tried
really hard I think in the opening I
gave black a little bit too much because
I think Claire is playing for a win at
some point and but I remember that you
know I had to exchange the Queen so we
went on the into the salon when you were
in endgame and at some point things
became really interesting because when I
took on c5 when he played nine a four
realized that black has decent
compensation on the pond and we were
running very short in time so I think
the critical mistake was when black I
decided to sacrifice an exchange on his
last move from the time control right it
bright it move 45 an exchange exactly we
see that mistake happen quite a bit
critical decisions right there all right
and if black we just play something
normal I think
the game would be a draw I mean probably
he was playing for a win but I wasn't
sure because I mean I missed some of his
strong moves like five and a ninety six
and then you know I was thinking to
myself damn this is gonna be a really
really tough game and of course once I
had an extra change and then it was a
matter of technique sort of like to find
the right squares from the pieces and
OMG most of course winning for white so
you're sitting at three and oh I mean
you couldn't have dreamt up a better
start this is a perfect start for you
how are you feeling about your chances
moving forward well I take one gained
much time as we roll dough because we're
all professionals here and I'm just
looking forward to playing more games
you know because I feel that I'm getting
more practiced you also look more rested
as well have you gotten your sleep in
because you were jet-lagged coming here
but it looks like you've maybe got
enough sleep in it it's a play no okay
yes you're right I was actually just
sleeping cold day and not really
preparing for the game because I
realized no gasps Larry we're gonna play
a long game and I was gonna matter the
amount of and shame and was gonna be
left standing at the end that's that's
about it and you are indeed the one
standing at the end congratulations on
your start and you win today thank you
Grandmaster gata Kamsky a true
professional three-time champ looking to
add to his laurels off to a perfect
start Jenny yes yes fantastic start by
gata Kamsky and you know it looks like
tomorrow we're probably gonna see gotta
face off against Conrad halt or John
Bryant I mean those are the only two
with a two and a half points so that
should be an interesting matchup yeah
kids nipping at his heels a half a point
behind but once again I have to say very
very professional smooth job great take
up I gotta he really looks like the
class in the field which he is and he's
proving it in exemplary fashion and he's
right on the mark
there with that exchange sacrifice just
coming at the end of the time control
I'm sure if Larry had a few extra
minutes I don't know exactly what the
time trouble situation was like but
making a critical decision just at the
end of the first time control turned out
to be
unfortunately for Larry the wrong one I
regret that Maurice he missed the
opportunity to ask God if he had seen
that 94-96 idea because that would have
been very interesting as well we have a
lot of other interviews here though Mike
lime doing things for the website so us
chess champs calm it's not just the six
hours a day or five hours a day you can
spend the rest of your five hours uh
really not fun at first hand reports and
more interviews absolutely but I do hope
that somebody catches gada and asked
them about that night pierette because
it's a pretty one oh it really was we
got so many pretty variations today on
both sides of the spectrum the strategic
94 which is obviously combined with
tactics but also has a strategic point
to that gorgeous variation from the
strip one ski game where there could
have been a night h7 that was really not
a one women
Camilla buy-in sky team started out with
zero out of two and you know suffered
some tough games in the first two rounds
but um she won against the Beno Poyser
so nice to see her getting on the
scoreboard
oh poor Sabina that's her third loss on
the trot oh looks like that game is
already over and Jelena Belikov Skye and
now has two points out of three and
interestingly enough that game is
actually ending as we speak it's
interesting that Angelina might be one
of the main persons to challenge
question this tournament well exactly I
mean wily veteran coming
back to play professionally looking very
good two out of three and very
impressive it is it just me or is this
this is a bloodthirsty round I mean
there's a lot of Bloody Sunday
yeah Bloody Bloody Sunday I mean I've
got on table one to do in three decisive
results white winning all the games of
one two and three only Joel Benjamin
managing to hold the black pieces on
board for whites by wins by a Cobian and
only shook on five and six I mean wow
devastating lots of really thought
around yeah and we just saw so many cool
things that's around the marshal
commercial attack and Larry Christianson
gata Kamsky you know butting heads and
it was a it was a really cool round or
every every round so far has been great
and I think they're gonna get even
bloodier as the tournament progresses if
that's possible I don't know if it's
possible you're not gonna believe this I
think
Maurice Pegg did it might as well in
that game between Alec Stravinsky and
Ray Robson alex is going to be kicking
himself that he didn't find that
beautiful tactical variation that Murray
showed but remarkably the Queen
overwhelmed the rook and two knights and
Ray Rob's and one of the pre-tournament
Dark Horse's shall we say crashed a
defeat again another win for white here
in LA I think we got in my ratings I
don't think maybe he was a dark horse in
terms of like winning the whole time at
dinner
yeah winning the whole Turner right
gotcha so it yeah pretty pretty
fascinating round and there's a couple
games still going on we got a we just
got Heston Orleans Hudson Nora wits is
the only remaining game and how's that
looking as we get a arena crusher set up
in studio it oh that backing descended
to and ended in a draw so Heston or oh
it's one of the only games in the
tournament
that wasn't decisive incredible exactly
this is around where only three of the
games in the men
section were drawn and now we yeah and
and the Women's Championship bloody is
ever and we have international master
Irina crash with Maurice Ashley to talk
about her latest victory in the women's
from Mendes fight a tremendous victory
for Irina crush congratulations on your
finish
thank you thank you Morris well she was
your main rival in the tournament she's
been your main rival for years now what
were you feeling going into the game
knowing that you had to player you know
I don't have any special feelings going
into these games Maurice I'm just trying
to do my best every game it's really
that's I know it's like the most boring
answer I can possibly give you but it's
true like I mean okay I felt I felt like
this game was course more important than
some other games because it's supposed
to be little bit harder you know because
of course Anna is uh you know that also
one of the highest rated players here so
you're expecting the game to be like a
tougher fight and you're I think maybe
now I'm a couple of points higher or
something with a new rating list but no
before that she was one point higher
than me you know it's pretty close so
yeah I was expecting this to be a tough
game the idea was to play something
solid and if I get a chance to try to
win I told the King Vince are you
supposed to King's Indian not exactly
the most solid opening or giving her all
that space but but you definitely was a
great maneuvering game and you guys
played battled all the way through and
at some point you played this fantastic
move Knight g4 that must have felt good
dropping that on the board yeah I had
seen that coming a little while ago
because I saw that she really didn't
have much of a plan okay you know can't
blame her didn't have much to do in that
position but so I saw she was going for
these checks and I saw the Queen g1 I
was like oh ninety-four interesting
opportunity because I all the time I
realized in that position my queen is
perfect my bishop is perfect and so my
knight has to be improved in order for
me to break through so I was actually
looking for a way to maybe get my Knight
to g5 you know target um efore and f3
without it being attacked by the Queen
in any way like it like it would be on
h4 so I had seen all these possible
sacrifices of the night for two pawns
given that the dark squared bishop was
not going to be able to help her and at
that moment yeah I saw Knight g4 I mean
I wasn't expecting her
I thought you know 92 was kind of a
better chance to sort of you know linger
on computer agrees with you that night
g2 is more of a talk yeah yes I didn't
seem completely clear to me in fact I
kind of missed it when I played Knight
g4 you know then I saw it I started
calculating into and she took on g4 I
was pretty surprised indeed you had I
believe Easter yesterday or do it's
today today but you you're Russian
Orthodox yeah and so you were out until
2:30 in the morning know at services
alright how did you manage to get energy
after being out so late and prepare and
do all that you had to do
actually Maurice I got back at 1:00 a.m.
I made I I went I didn't stay for the
entire service you know I sort of
consideration of the fact that I had to
play today and I couldn't just sleep in
so that was my compromise you know I
went to church about my the driver
picked me up at 10:15 and I got back
around 1:00 and it's funny on the way
back
my taxi driver you know he picked me up
at church and you know he said silently
for a while and he's like so can I ask
you a question and I'm like go ahead
he's like do you believe in God I
thought it was really funny I had a
feeling what he felt about it you know
but so then we had a whole conversation
about that when he explained to me that
he was an atheist and you know how do
you how did the Bible explain the
dinosaurs and things like that yeah so
yeah this is a great midnight
conversation yeah well you're supposed
to be thinking about chess now I don't
mind that you know if someone wants
wants to talk about that that's a good
thing so now you're sitting at three a
No mmm what are your thoughts moving
forward to keep adding points you know I
just want to keep playing well I feel
like since the first round like I said I
played better yesterday I played pretty
well today and I just want to keep that
going keep that momentum going and not
give anyone an easy time is it hard to
start not look too far ahead I mean
after beating your main rival especially
we in you know in the press are saying
that is your main rival yeah is it is it
hard to keep that perspective on well I
just have to play around for you know
it's funny Maurice I don't even know who
I'm playing tomorrow I only looked I
only looked three days ahead because I
knew these three days
would be the toughest for me just in
terms of the schedule because it was
Holy Week and I spent a lot of time in
church less time for you know preparing
so these days were pretty tell offense I
only kind of saw this far so I'm not
even sure who I'm playing tomorrow it's
kind of like a new tournament and begins
you know again tomorrow very
professional attitude will
congratulations on your victory today
and best of luck in the rest of the team
you're in a crush at 3a no the only
perfect score in the women's event back
to you Jenny yes well Irena is going to
be playing against angelina Belikov skya
with the white pieces so Angelina has
two out of three now actually so that
should be a very interesting battle as
well and one that we're gonna keep a
close eye on absolutely so yes Irena
crush and gata Kamsky emerging as clear
leaders in the US Championships and u.s.
women's chess championships today and
boy did we have a lot of fun today
grandmasters Yasir Sarah Juan Maurice
Ashley and all these fantastic guests we
had visiting guests and our usual usual
grandmasters coming down to talk about
their games I had a lot of fun today
if you missed some of it we do have
replays of the round by round coverage
on us chess champs calm so especially
for the coming days when some of you
might have to go to work and you know
you want to see the whole show you can
get that after the after the broadcast
which is a great service u.s. chess
champs comm keep it bookmarked for these
two weeks absolutely and the big shout
out of thanks to our Susan Polgar are
visiting women's world champion and also
to all of our guests who just came to
watch great event here in st. Louis
thank you all
absolutely students from Lindenwood and
of course all the players who like to
come downstairs and get get trolled by
Maurice before they they start preparing
for their next game so thanks thanks to
all the producers and to the Chess Club
and we will see you tomorrow for more
from the US chess championships and one
o'clock local time 2:00 p.m. Eastern
you